[Music]
hi uncles
i'm uncle fester so i did a high uncle
okay
love that i'm not letting the james
charles thing go
i love it that's your thing though is
like not letting things go like that's
your that is your job
i think it's funny you know that and
also that it upsets people so much but
today i'm uncle i am
uncle fester from the adams family what
is this uncle fester nobody knows who i
am which is so crazy except for tick
tock hey
um i am jennifer from jennifer's body a
great movie by diablo cody starring
amanda seaford megan fox
um she's a zombie eating cheerleader
zombie eat wait you eat zombies you said
zombie eating
boy eating she's a zombie everyone says
vampires like you crapping feeling the
zombie
she's not a zombie actually i thought
that was half dead i thought that was a
really interesting premise someone who
eats zombies that's kind of cool
it's like fresh and unique i mean that
would be a cool one yeah i mean maybe
that could be a concept
yeah i just wanted to be cute for tick
tocks and only fans so like
when i came up with the i came up with
the idea to do halloween episodes i did
not think you would participate but i
wanted to forewarn you that i was going
to be in costume
not knowing you were going to take it to
this like extra level that you have
taken it yeah i was just going to ask if
you're embarrassed
for the second week to sit next to me
had i known you were going to be like
so intricate first of all i didn't think
you had hair makeup people which you
didn't you asked for my hair
people just totally fine love giving
them work but i'm just saying yeah i
didn't think oh he's not going to have
the hair makeup like i do
that's what i do that's my thing i
always look like the character and then
you were all of a sudden once you got my
hair makeup people just like oh he's
gonna like really step it up
and so i literally i messaged you and i
said
just so you know well you should have
known from last week after i showed up
as james charles
you should have known i said just so you
know i'm going all out
again so don't say i didn't warn you i
know but
and then the first thing you say when
you show up is like oh somebody should
have told me
yeah i shaved my eyebrows and i shaved
my whole [ __ ] head this is not a
prosthetic there's not
some kind of [ __ ] part of the trick
i shaved
all my [ __ ] hair off i was ready to
shave my my eyelashes
but everyone said no don't do it yeah
well you also should have done the
eyebrows because when you take the
makeup off you're gonna look
crazy yeah it takes like five months
apparently to grow them back
yeah i have a fault you want to see me
just normal yeah wait oh without with no
eyebrows
yeah i took a photo before oh my gosh
but the thing is
i kind of wanted them to do um
i don't know why nobody proposed doing
that here that's what i look like
you don't look bad not that bad right
who do you look like you kind of look
like someone like paul giamatti maybe
who's that you know who called your
money is
who's paul junior are you being so
serious we're on your mother's life
[ __ ] is paul gioman are you kidding do
you think i would waste time
precious mo oh that's okay
you're a [ __ ] that's the worst photo of
him
he is actually so hot and sideways if
you talk while you're married sideways
like he's so hot in that movie like he's
actually
you're comparing me to pig vomit oh okay
yes knowing that that's his name from
you know i know
wait why don't you like mention howard
stern you're like have this like this
weird thing you said your audience comes
for you when you mention howard stern
like i love how i was learning like
refuse to talk about him
like you don't like talking about him
you don't like mentioning like his name
talk about him cuz he said like oh that
movie like you don't really say his
name howard stern's private parts i just
referenced the character in the movie
um he's jewish him and adam sandler read
the torah on his show like the other day
they literally or what was it torah
something i don't know so anyway um hey
so i went all out
and uh i'm gonna regret it but i i i was
like listen
you know i wanted to look good i wanted
to go out but if she would have
suggested maybe doing it with glue
but does it look as good with glue no
you definitely definitely committed more
with shaving the eyebrows but now you're
gonna have to be for
all the episodes to come till march
you're gonna have no eyebrows i think
it's funny though in a way
oh i have to just live through the
mystery of having no eyebrows
for a while to look at and you have an
anniversary trip this weekend like
you're not gonna have sex this weekend
like i could never have sex with someone
no i'd rather she'll bag me no offense
anyone what what she'll bag me
bag she'll be back bag over your head
yeah is that what you do is that a thing
i've never heard yeah she'll bag me
i could see that for sure i could see
that is that a thing
i it yes
so what so how was your weekend it was
great what is this what are you doing i
just want to like okay so
uh we have i made this special candle
okay you remember gwyneth paltrow smells
like my vagina candy i remember you
talking about it i don't really remember
i made a candle i said [ __ ] her why does
the girls get all the fun
i just made a candle smells like my
butthole this is a real one
are you really selling it yes i swear
and all the prophets go to prostate
cancer wait are you serious yeah how did
you get this made how do you guys have
it took a while because we're [ __ ]
because we take things seriously we make
some connections like this
no try it oh
my god but it's unique right it's not
just
it's not like just farts it's like a
real smell oh my god
that's so disgusting yeah what
who made that this is everything yeah oh
my god so
anyway this is iconic last year when
gwyneth made her candle we're like this
is [ __ ] stupid this is gonna light it
no don't light it yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's gonna be worse
it'll be available in like a month
but we first of all we worked with the
essence company to
perfect the perfume scent and um
oh my god i was just i was specifically
like i don't want just sulfur because
you could just get fart liquid and
smells like farts
but i was like no no it's got to smell
like musky pubie
bioefficient yeah that's what my
butthole smells like
it doesn't smell so bad it doesn't smell
like a fart it smells just more like
yeah like a moist butthole like you have
a shower for the day
yeah exactly and so but so i really was
trying to be true to form here and uh
and yeah all the profits are going to go
to prostate cancer
awareness or research whatever all of it
all these poor men with
ass cancer that'd be awful wait it's
asking oh it is yes cancer yes the ass
cancer
and so they'll be available in a month
or so okay now what try this watch
no what i don't want to smell it why are
you blowing it my way
oh my god that smells so bad
i hate burps i hate oh my god that
sounds so horrible
that when it burn when it blows out is
oh my god i hate that stuff like
anything like that like oh
so anyway how was your weekend oh that's
so
you know i almost didn't agree to even
do this podcast because moses told me
like you burp a lot and i hate burping
so much he said you burp a lot i don't
burp almost at all
oh well farting all of that and i hate
all of it
i mean i don't burp or fart in front of
my guests
but have you ever seen me burp or fart i
just got nervous
have you ever seen me burp or fall i'm
not a guest anymore this is our fifth
episode i know
is it yeah yeah wow congrats all right
let's get to some business this is
stupid this is boring
i hate that you already downplay
everything like what the hell
you were the one that convinced me that
our last episode was like trash and then
everyone's like
we love that episode so you should i
didn't really follow my lead
okay let me pull up my notes happy
anniversary by the way i'm congrats on
marriage thank you you guys are very
sweet actually you're very open-minded
that you don't care that i do only fans
last week you thought that we weren't
romantic and you thought our
relationship was a sham
i noticed you stepped it up on instagram
now you guys are like love her hottie
i've always listened to you i have it i
followed you guys for a year and you
never okay
so here here i've got it it's like love
him i've got a bunch of stuff i want to
get to today
so let's cut through the [ __ ] oh my
god first of all
last last um last week you admitted you
don't know
what the holocaust is or why oh my god
are we really gonna go
so i asked you to watch schindler's list
even ask me
watched schindler's list and i was like
no but also okay let me just do it like
you said yes i'd love to that would be
awe i said it would be funny you watched
endlessly
okay yeah stop with the [ __ ] no my
initial reaction was like yes i'm
excited to watch this because everyone's
got it and i don't know so initially i
was like yes i'm down
liam neeson ralph fiennes i'm down i'm
in for this movie
do you have questions about it were you
surprised that a movie about the
holocaust was sad
oh yeah it was way too sad we started
like watching it
and then our dinner arrived and i felt
really sad eating like mac and cheese
while someone was getting blown in the
seat
eating the mac and cheese is sad enough
it was i felt so fat that day because
i'd panda express it that for lunch and
then i had the mac and cheese for dinner
i'm like wow i'm really fat
but then um we watched it and it was
really sad
and it was audibly hard to hear like
just my only critique schindler's list
is like i get it it's sad and it was
like
it was probably a great movie that went
oscars but like audibly i couldn't hear
them it wasn't an accent thing it wasn't
like
i just couldn't the audio was horrible
they didn't have subtitles
you know you could turn on subtitles oh
no stop
you don't know how to turn off i don't
have subtitles does this have subtitles
yeah every well yeah actually it does it
has captions
all right stop i didn't know anyways
aside from the subtitles like auto
let me read this horrible and it's black
and white which i feel was a cop-out
whoever directed that film
steven spielberg director okay i think
he knows
i think he cheapened out with it by not
having to do it in color like you for
blood you probably just use like
chocolate syrup or something you know
rather than like
what you're saving on the budget
literally chocolate syrup
i think so because all right let me read
what you want to do he would go full out
shout out quentin let me oh yeah that
that would be appropriate in uh the
schindler's list
some samurai sword [ __ ] and blood skirt
and everywhere no but he didn't glorious
batman
i'd love to see yeah schindler's list
should have
uh really graphic or you're right and
who they all look the same
they literally all look the same i was
so confused who and they all have
they all wear the armbands not just the
nazis the jews were the armbands
everyone were armbands i'm like i'm so
confused who's the good guy who's the
bad guy
and even the jews were on the bad guys
side i was so confused like the jews
were like
on the the bad guys i was so i was just
how do you
this is insane do you care yeah he hated
it too
well this but this is like this is not
the takeaway you're supposed to get from
schindler's list we watched
we did watch the ending on youtube but
we couldn't understand the ending he was
just really
you skipped to that either he was upset
or happy either he thought he could
freeze
he was stoked that yeah because he freed
all those people and they're like thank
you
yeah that's exactly what happened why
would he be sad how could you
misinterpret that he said
i could have sold this ring and saved
more lives oh i did not hear i couldn't
hear it
i just know he started crying homework
you know you are so
that they saved all the people they're
like thank you we got saved and i
couldn't understand if he was happier is
that and neither
we could understand like we tried we
tried i feel like i'm living through a
second holocaust right now
with me or just like without you here
let me read your text message you sent
me
you said we only washed one third of it
we tried
i said you couldn't finish it no i
watched the ending on youtube though so
i kind of get it
we were eating mac and cheese i felt
weird to watch people's head being blown
off from behind
at the same time i was eating mac and
cheese it was okay
couldn't hear anything we could still
talk might not be great at quiz though
i get the [ __ ] of it well i thought
you might quiz me so i was like trying
to
give you the heads up like i only
watched like a third of it
so i didn't know if we were cooperating
so so we're recording this on monday is
it indigenous people day or christopher
columbus day
oh today's christopher columbus day
indigenous people day no what okay
if you are way too pc these days that's
not a thing like
is it a thing i don't know it is a thing
because christopher columbus
well you know that the native americans
was the group one of the the single
largest genocide in human history
50 million i didn't know that 50 to 60
million native americans died because
people like christopher columbus oh he
killed them yeah disease
and slavery and just straight-up
genocide killing them did you know this
or did you research this for today
i think literally everybody knows that i
don't think so why do we celebrate
thanksgiving then we're celebrating
the death of indigenous people well
thanksgiving was more about the triumph
of the two different
communities coming together but
christopher columbus is definitely
celebrating
someone who came and conquered the
natives and committed genocide on them
and raped them and stuff
oh okay so we should not be celebrating
today then well
it's a it's it's a it's a tough one
because christopher columbus is such an
important
historical figure but he's also you know
wages genocide on
on uh and killed 50 million native
americans that's so sad
yeah you wouldn't watch the movie though
you just watched there's a movie on it
you would skip it there's not a movie on
it i watch i watch
i watch historical movies i watch
glorious bastards i watch like those
kind of movies yeah but those are
those are actually just fiction though
okay but they're
in a time era they're in time period
okay so
happy christopher columbus day but not
to the people who kill native americans
should we just say that
well he did kill him so what do we say
okay happy individuals indigenous people
thank you for finding america right or
being here i guess thank you for being
here
thank you for being in the mirror thanks
for being here you're not anymore
no they are like batanga and stuff
they're all who was it that said this
joke and
i think it was chappelle he says put it
this way when was the last time you saw
two
native americans together at the same
time
oh why because we [ __ ] well we i mean
i was my ancestors weren't here at the
time they were in the holocaust
yeah we were over there getting the
business on the other end
that's so bad i feel so bad for the jews
damn they're [ __ ] in the ghetto
where's your family did were your family
slave owners and [ __ ] no
no but serious i shouldn't even say this
because it's going to be too
controversial but i
i did do a 23andme and i have ancestors
that were from africa
how much yeah you're have some black i
think it was like literally like 13
but that's like 13 african yeah but i
don't want to say that
like people are going to come for me
like okay you're trying to people well
why you're just stating your genetics oh
look i have
i have the breakdown because i sent it
in a while ago and then i got the email
like
my spam because i was like hey i sent
this in and like oh well we sent it to
you so they resent it and went to spam
or
13 black oh god don't make that a
headline because i don't want it to be a
controversial thing
i'm titling that's a [ __ ] please don't
everyone come to me if i think i'm
anything i don't know if those are
accurate i don't think they're are you
going to make a video saying that you're
you identify african-american no
i don't and i don't because i don't know
but like i my point is i don't know
where my ancestors were but i
i think like i think we i don't know
no i think we all were like like slaves
at some point
we as in you and me because you were
jewish and i'm what are you
i think i'm 18. i don't know i think
that's right i don't know
what are you i don't know i think i
might have a little bit in me but i
don't want to say that like you
huh no like african american oh so you
think you're
because you're 13 black that you were
part uh you're a slave oh no i didn't
know because if you're thirty percent
black it's more likely that
well your ancestors probably you know
raped slaves
i didn't know they didn't oh my god i'm
not going there
no but where's the what's the other uh
what's the other night you know 87
percent
um i have some i have mostly greek and
hungarian and then there's like
oh there's some there's some other stuff
um
no i'm not i'm not a mikey over here
oh by the way can what happened to um
first of all can we get dave chappelle
on our show
you look like uncle fester that's crazy
maybe you could be in the reboot
i know where's my are we going go ahead
uh whenever you're in yeah i want to be
i do want to be uncle fester would you
actually like if they asked you to be in
a new way yeah i did
really i'll be uncle fester you'd be so
good you look you look like it
oh my god the ears and the face
wow oh my god my camera this one
that's how you were meant to be this is
crazy and you would
you should totally do it okay so
as you remember i dominated you in
trivia last week
oh gosh and uh you sent me 1500 thank
you very much
and so as an act of redemption and
charity to you
i said okay you want to you say you have
all this fast knowledge in broadway
music oh no
so i put together just for you
broadway musical trivia you put these
questions together
well the guys did okay are you competing
with me or no because i
i don't know anything i'll just ask you
a few wait why are we doing this it just
makes me look stupid
no i i i thought that you would look
smart because you know so much
out of this here we just wait for the
fun for that and which musical does
teenager tracy
turn blad break the mold when she
auditions to dance
on the corny collins i was like what am
i even reading
it's called nonsense hairspray okay of
course i know that which musical has won
the most tony awards in history
oh my god like this kind of stuff i
don't know tony where oh
hello hamilton no the producers the oh
my god really we just watched it the
other day which musical contains the
song the story of tonight
oh hamilton got him got him
what is the name of the musical based on
monty python on the holy grail spam a
lot
okay you're doing good which musical
debuted on
broadway the earliest kinky boots or
hamilton
oh kinky boots that's easy yeah these
are so easy which music
which musical contains the song sos
oh mamma mia i'm impressed
for which animated musical film did sir
elton john win an academy award
there it is which year did music movie
musical chicago
when best film oscar um say it again
and which year did movie musical chicago
win best film
in what year yeah 2003
you got it what is the longest running
musical on broadway
oh fan of the opera that's right which
music contains the song memory
cats yep which do you like cats cause i
hear
i hate it i hate cats yeah i always hear
people saying they hate
did you see the movie i saw i mean the
movie i just saw
bits and pieces and it was just so
horrible it was just unbelievable i
wonder if they did that as a troll
though to make it horrible like
no they lost like 100 million dollars
that's a hell of a troll
that's like me shaving my eyebrows it's
like i'm gonna troll everybody by
shaving my eyebrows and then you're like
[ __ ] i gotta live like this for five
months it's iconic
which musical is based on the book by
gregory mcguire
based on the oh greg mcguire i have no
idea wicked
oh wow i didn't know steven sondheim did
the music didn't know who did the book
so
which character was played by zenai's
renee zellweger and the film adaption
yeah which group's music is featured in
mamma mia
which musical contains the song summer
nights greece these are so easy
i don't know any of these which musical
tells the story of two drag queens and a
transgender woman who are
contracted to perform a drag show at
alice springs
oh they're gonna come from you priscilla
queen of the desert i've never saw him
sorry which musical contains the song
do-ray means
that's kind of music which rock musical
with
ages or is it a different one nope was
it the great you want me to finish the
question yeah with music by andrew lloyd
webber
school of rock nope wait what rock
musical
starlight express oh i guess i should
let you finish sorry
there's so many if my friends could see
me now was the song from which musical
um i know the song if they could see me
now that little gang of mine
i'm drinking dancing sweet charity yeah
[ __ ]
that's an old one which musical contains
the song i dream to dream uh
um oh i dreamed a dream uh les mis yeah
which music contains the song seasons of
love oh rent okay
125 000. you know what six hundred no i
don't mean
it's you don't know any of those wow
those are those are pretty basic those
are pretty easy
well you got yeah you did pretty good i
really was like lyrics and songs like i
feel like that would have been my forte
but thank you for
reading my redemption do i get something
from that no no
you get a little more you just get a
little you get to feel yeah a little
street i can't be on broadway we should
be on broadway they have adam's family
on broadway we could both be in it okay
so let's talk about some drama you've
been in
let's not let's talk about that's how
you wanted yeah no i'm excited what do
you want to talk about because i have
more stuff you want make your car do you
want to talk things i have so many
things to talk about so many things
um where do we start i don't even know
like when i get heated i get like really
like uh i miss doing these like rant
videos because when i get heat i want to
talk about it like here's the thing i
just never want to insert myself into
drama but now that i
now that like our job is to comment on
drama like i feel like i can
i feel like joy behar on the view or
something where they just like
talk about drama just to talk you know
what i mean just to talk about it
so i feel like that's us so what do you
want to talk about yeah um there is
mikey patrick starr james charles
commenting crystalia there's so much to
talk about and i don't know where to
start whoa whoa whoa crystal yeah is he
back in the news
no that was my whole point though chris
leon was on your show what happened to
him do you know do you have inside
information oh no i don't have inside
information you never talked to him we
haven't talked to him since the scandal
where did he go and why is he hiding
well i don't blame him for not wanting
to be in the
but what did he do that was so bad
here's the thing right so he talked
under these girls like hey i'm 17 he
stopped talking to them right
because he's like oh you can't really
show it that you're afraid look i'm the
first to condemn old creepy guys hitting
on young girls but at the same
time he didn't do anything wrong but did
he do something wrong because he was
hiding oh he did oh well there were
stories like in the la times there were
corrobor
that peop like corroborated by people
and like super credible
where they like told this one story
where he like
met this girl and then he had her like
drive out somewhere to give his friend a
[ __ ] or something
and there was another one where like was
she under age no she wasn't
so i guess it's just a little creepy he
didn't do anything illegal
right so it's a another one
of like where two girls came over to his
hotel room after a show and he like
pulled out his [ __ ] he's like who's
gonna soak my dick
not a bit not illegal but they left and
he didn't try to like force them to do
anything
just a little creepy behavior so he's
creepy so he's going to hide how many
creepy people are in
hollywood woody allen is still making
movies which i don't know i don't know
but it's just that like he lost
all of his gigs like he was doing this
huge accent film on netflix that they're
like
recasting now oh my god he talks so much
about that on his podcast
and his podcast he just abandoned like
he had such a popular thing and he's
just like goodbye yeah you know he was
on top of the world
he can't just say like i'm sorry like
i'm a [ __ ] creep like
i have a white kid now but why are we
talking about chris lee this is like old
because you're friends with him
when i was just like where did he go and
i felt like you had inside information
that you could tell i'm not i don't have
inside information
you haven't texted him hey how you doing
man
no i don't think he wants to hear from
me we're not that close he was on your
podcast a couple times you think he just
used you for clout
it's not you it's not everything is
using people i think i hate when there's
just like a using like relationship like
i'm gonna go on their questions what am
i i i've done over 200 well over 200
episodes i have to keep in touch with
every single guest
i think you should i think that's like
the polite thing to do yeah but you can
bitched about me texting you so what's
your plan
well i'm no longer a guest now i'm a
co-host on this
panel okay what else you want to talk
about
um we have patrick starr
doing his beetlejuice tutorial okay
first of all i'm a huge fan of
beetlejuice my nails are beetlejuice i'm
not a spongebob
character patrick starr no i'm serious
yeah isn't that his name that's not
beauty guru anymore
he's [ __ ] spongebob who's the city
with the spongebob wait you don't know
patrick star
oh are you being serious i never know so
everything you say to me you're like
being serious when you don't know yes
so you really didn't know paul giamatti
i i
the name was familiar to me and i
recognized him but you don't know
patrick starr
let me look up patrick okay it's not
shade i'm not familiar with this [ __ ]
he was popular he was talk about shade
okay so what about him okay beetlejuice
he just did a beetlejuice video and he
said oh today
he's like i'm a huge fan of beetlejuice
i'm doing this look inspired by
beetlejuice today
the great movie starring kevin costner
wrong idiot i mean that's so offensive
that's literally so that'd be like
saying oh i love the movie selena
like uh selma hayek did such a great job
as her like
you know what i'm saying that's like a
little bit is it more or less offensive
than eating mac and cheese during
schindler's list first of all i didn't
know there was going to be people's
heads blown off in schindler's i didn't
know that's why it's the holocaust i
didn't know about the holocaust i didn't
know what happened i didn't okay
whatever yeah literally but you're
you're more offended because this dude
misnamed an actor and beetlejuice it's
not just an actor and just beetle it's
it's the most iconic movie ever and my
whole house is dedicated to beetlejuice
i spent all my money
my health currently is beetlejuice the
new house we're getting is going to be
prince of egypt this one's beetlejuice
wrong we love a theme you love it i'm
trying to think how to put this
delicately
you're the one that's like oh i'm gonna
go out for one freaking episode bro my
house isn't [ __ ] beetlejuice things
look
michael keaton is literally the most
iconic person that's ever lived and it's
so insulting to say
and you're gonna do a whole estuarine on
beetlejuice and not know
that well i'm surprised you kept it in
it's like edited out or something you
know what i mean
that nobody around him he's like someone
with a team he gets like 12 people
around him at all times
and no one said it i'm gonna get shaded
for this too because i was like i know
someone's gonna be like oh trash blah
like james charles came from everyone's
just coming for me
look is this really drama though let's
be honest is this really dramatic
the drama i was pissed about was mikey
like that's the drama okay so we're
giving so hold on yeah we'll get there
so patrick starr
we are saying shame shame to you patrick
star
you piece of [ __ ] you inhuman
scum forgetting what do you say michael
keaton with
no beetlejuice starring kevin costner
you [ __ ] up that's like confusing like
denzel washington morgan freeman like oh
i love like denzel washington and like
bruce almighty you know like it's like
that's a little worse because you're
like mixing black guys
i'm saying people that are that are
often confused
michael keaton and who kevin costner are
they often confused no that's what i'm
saying though i'm just saying like
okay if you have what to say one thing
to patrick star say it into the camera
thing
which is this is my camera yeah patrick
starr
i love you you're doing it let's do that
one yeah
i love you you're doing great things but
beetlejuice is iconic and it's cool if
you're gonna
if you're gonna recreate an iconic
character at least put some respect
on michael keaton and then you also
mentioned broadway's beetlejuice and you
didn't even mention alex breitman who
was also iconic as beetlejuice who saved
the winter garden last year
so please with some respect on
beetlejuice a movie by tim burton not
starring kevin costner but michael
keaton thank you
ouch are you gonna tell us trisha
peterson's message to magic star you
use my name still in all the highlights
that's the whole point of this show
talk about no not what exactly i'm not i
don't want to talk about this every
episode
oh my god but you did it again this week
i'm gonna do it every week
why don't you put ethan hates somebody
you know i would
i would if i if there was that of course
you ever seen our normal highlights it's
like
ethan goes after the pope i have all
this crazy [ __ ] who does the titles
oh we do it as a team who's actually no
i blame ian ian does it
really i'll just absolve all
responsibility
i just let him take all the blame love
that um
yeah okay so far so we were saying star
okay so who else let's lead up to the
big drama so who's the other like
is there someone else leading up before
we get to uh james charles you know what
i never had what happened with james
charles i never had an issue with him
and i
really didn't but i can see why now pete
why people don't like him because he's
so
condescending with his remarks look
here's the thing i don't when people
talk [ __ ] about me or whatever if i talk
about someone i expect someone to clap
back right like you can't just mention
me
and knock somebody to clap back vice
versa if i mention you like you you can
clap back be cute be snarky whatever
but his condescending level is what
pisses me off so like
there was i think it was like on a
spilling tea video or something like
that like like spill the tea or
something i don't know what it's some
drama video that said like trisha paytas
versus james shaw whatever um which i
had no problem with him and he literally
just commented well he must have watched
the video because i said something like
oh everybody i know has a problem with
james charles and he commented just like
so
just so like he's just like oh everybody
she knows i'm like
that's your clap back like you can't
think of something a little smarter like
actually i'll say when i was bitching
about him last week you were saying nice
things about him
you weren't being mean to him at all and
all he said was everybody i know has a
problem with him
i always said i don't have a problem
with him like i was like hey let's
collab i need those tick tock views
who comments on a t video like how
[ __ ]
sad is that [ __ ] i mean he must like
love it like i feel like he loves the
the drama of people talking about him
right who doesn't like i watch i don't
watch those videos because people are
too harsh on me but
um jeffree star unfollowed me i don't
know why but that's
wait i thought you guys were dogs yeah
he unfollowed well i think we had like a
little issue earlier this summer where i
didn't like defend him as hard as i
defended shane so i feel like maybe
there was an issue there i don't know
jeffrey i'm sorry we had a little issue
in vegas hey he unfollowed you did that
break your heart did you
yeah unfollows pretty a pretty hard
rejection
like like i'm not gonna lie you know how
many people does he follow
um i don't know but it was like a big
thing like you can mute somebody you
know what i mean to unfollow someone's
big like that's a rebuke
right like i'm done with this person
yeah but jeffree star always struck me
as a [ __ ]
freak but like no he's he's
he's such a [ __ ] weirdo yeah i mean
like just his whole
yeah that's a good point so that's what
i'm saying like i kind of like always
related i think he has a little bit too
much oh he only follows 95 people so
that was like an epic rebuke of you
yeah right and he got to just mute me i
was like damn he follows taco bell
yeah and not europe i know well who
wouldn't honestly but the drama channels
picked it up and i didn't know so i
unfollowed him but then
maybe i shouldn't have made it back yeah
because i saw the dog was like jeffree
star and paul's christian i'm like oh my
god should i unfollow him too
and i did but now i feel bad which i
re-follow him maybe well no if he's not
gonna follow you
you know [ __ ] him yeah i don't know i
mean it was whatever
but he also strikes me not not nothing
to do with the way he looks just as a
very odd dude like in a
i don't know he just he always gave me
the heebie-jeebies
uh i could see that i mean before i met
him i felt that way too i mean he was
always super cool to me until like the
last trip he like made fun of my weight
and skin and stuff like that so he made
fun of your weight
yeah the guy that was filming and
stopped becoming friends with him and
he's like filming him like talking what
did he say about you
just that i was fat i had greasy skin
and my hair sucked
what why would he say that about you i
don't know it was shocking because he
invited me on this trip and i didn't go
out with him to the club he's also kind
of like
peace and love and everything but like
if he's making fun of your weight he
strikes me as like kind of anorexic
he's like super yeah and i think he has
easy i think he's sensitive to like
people calling him that too you know
like saying he has aids and stuff like
that like people will say that
i didn't even think about it no i know i
mean but he looks like he has aids no
i didn't say that but that someone
pretending to be his last boyfriend said
that
i get it like like i never thought about
saying wait his last boyfriend said he
has aids
his last boyfriend came up with like a
fake twitter fake instagram like someone
faked his last boyfriend this andre guy
yeah they made a fake oh that was all
fake yeah i guess
that sounds fishy well i didn't really
investigate into it really but
he has aids though yeah i mean but i
could tell it was like a troll account
you know what i mean but we can't even
talk about it jeffrey starts that he's
gonna sue everybody that talks about
this he can't sue us for talking about
it well sue h3 podcast channel not me
i'm not i'm just an employee
you can sue me yeah that's not my first
rodeo
really you know but do you mind a
lawsuit i'll buy nuns of course i don't
want a lawsuit
but i'm just saying i'm not going to be
i'm not going to be silenced yeah i
like respect that same i'll like talk
about [ __ ] like jacksonville
well he can sue you for slander okay
what are we we're not slandering
we're we're speaking hypothetically
we're wondering i don't i'm not saying
this this would be slight okay don't do
it don't do it don't do it no but no
i'm not saying it i'm just saying this
would be slander take that clip and then
no but in the whole comments
jeffrey starr has aids and i have proof
of it
that's not good but i don't have proof
but i don't have proof
and for all i know he doesn't have eight
he yes no but if i
said if you said i'm not in this if
trisha went online it said
jeffree star has super aids
and i have proof i don't condone this
fyi
you never said that but still you're
just saying that it's perpetuating it
it's like it's like igniting it more
yeah okay okay but i don't have proof
for the record
and he doesn't have aids as far as i'm
aware and then jaclyn hill said she was
gonna sue me
because or what because i talked about
her for talking about her in my
instagram story wait who's jacqueline
hill now i'm trying to follow the drama
she did a video on her last year on her
hairy lipsticks remember the girl with
the hairy lipsticks wait i did
oh she had the [ __ ] the it had like
rot in it
oh [ __ ] so was she's back no she's not
back but
um well she just she just came for me oh
she just i once people suddenly come for
me if you're gonna come for me just say
my name
jeff too last year people don't say my
name but they'd like to insinuate
the person talking come on say it
wait i don't want to call her a [ __ ]
because that's rude so what if i call
her a bad
word a [ __ ] isn't a rude word
i guess it depends how you use it yeah i
don't like calling women [ __ ] because
it feels very chauvinistic
maybe for me but if i say batch comfort
me batch that's okay
batch bet yeah look yeah tell me what
happened with jacqueline hill why is she
coming for you um
i guess because i made stories saying
she threatened to sue her ex-husband
because her ex-husband was talking to me
about something and
i it's just i'm gonna see you about what
i i guess they have like an nda i
probably shouldn't be talking about this
they have an nda in their divorce so
it's not your problem if they have an
nda
you're not an nda that's what i'm
thinking too but if he's gonna sue
you it's his problem jacqueline's gonna
sue me for talking about no she can sue
him for breaking it oh maybe that was it
but i don't want her to sue him either
him
no i know he's a good guy i want the
team there's no
t there's just jacqueline is like did
you [ __ ] her ex or something
no well yes but that's not good oh no
wonder she hates you
wait when did you [ __ ] her up no this
was like last year this was like last
december this is a while ago
but um no wait of course she hates you
when did you
how long after they broke up did you she
cheated on him with his best friend
kicked him out while he was
you know that whole thing oh i can't
keep up with this can i just say can i
just say she thinks that he told me this
no if you go in the
photos of her current boyfriend he was
friends with her ex-husband years before
and then all of a sudden
oh they get together all of a sudden
like and he's kicked to the curb
someone's by the way they got married
when they were 17
before she had money kicked him to the
curb and started dating his like best
friend that worked in the recording
studio like
months later or something no absolutely
not so he has a cringe
youtube channel about cooking because
he's trying to be like jacqueline now
like hey guys welcome to my cooking show
like he's not hot anyways she's a good
guy
she likes his companionship huh maybe
he's a good guy oh really
oh really someone that's gonna [ __ ] his
best friend's wife that's a good guy
no exactly so i don't mind coming for
his cooking channel
should i watch his cooking channel video
sure cooking with barnum or something
cooking with farnam so many people are
going to go to this
video farnam all right let's see what
this idiot's up to
wait where is it no wait cooking with
foreign
man oh farnam far far and hum
no farm um num farn
um hum um i type tom farnhum
cooking with farnam well he doesn't okay
oh his channel is called more seasoning
exclamation
[Laughter]
all right you want a scallop risotto
easy and amazing how many views did you
get
20 000 from one week ago okay not as
much clout
wow it must be embarrassing to be him
why
because he doesn't get any views i know
well you know it's fine if you don't get
views it's just don't be cocky
oh he's wearing a venti shirt what is he
a baller why is he acting like he's rich
she's a baller she's like i don't know
what she was
but she might still be i don't know they
live in florida she's buying him clothes
apparently
yo for sure buying him clothes
you know you're not gonna ever get there
bro he might after today
oh he passed it already oh yeah he
smashed it
that way why do i hate this guy again
i'm like no we don't hate him we don't
we don't i hate watch him because he's
so cringy
so this guy [ __ ] his best friend's
wife yep they were in the recording
studio together he used to film videos
for him
that's bad and now he's living in their
house that they lived in together oh
what the [ __ ]
oh i know it's a little ooh so what's
the exit so you [ __ ] the ex was it a
pity [ __ ] or do you like him
no i was like into him he was the one i
told you when i first came on your
podcast in january i was like oh it's
kind of ruined the last guy's lives that
i was with i ruined his life because i
was kind of like
you ruined his life i think so i feel
bad i know
why'd you ruin his well he was kind of
seeing someone which i didn't know he
was kind of seeing someone when he came
out to stay with me for like 10 days
over new year's
and then i guess he tried to call her
and i got pissed because he tried to
call her while he was in my house being
like oh my god look i miss you and i was
like what the [ __ ] like what he we were
like whatever
and i was like what the [ __ ] and then he
called me her name and whatever so
i kind of ruined his life by telling the
girl like yeah we [ __ ] right he's like
don't tell her that
well wait was he was cheating on her
with you
what's up look he's actually a good guy
and like it doesn't sound like it no
he's like he's just broken he's just
like a broken guy which i can relate but
i don't know i wish them well i hope
they they get together but jaclyn's like
obsessed with him still and so whatever
i shouldn't be talking about this like
i'm gonna get
okay let's move on yeah no let's cut it
actually
no we're not cutting it why don't you
cut anything because i
why we cut sometimes look can we talk
about someone you who don't like or that
you hate
mandy do you hate watch anybody oh do i
hate watching i don't have that much
time i don't watch that much youtube
lately
you knew about the mic you knew about
everything you knew about all these
things yeah because these guys do
research for me and i looked up
the most juicy one i'll say is um
so anthony padilla yes let's talk about
this he's excited his girlfriend
mikey of glam and gore well because
we've talked about this before and it's
our most disliked highlight of all time
is you versus anthony padilla
him calling you out for faking mental
illness or whatever
and so it turns out that his girlfriend
then the two of them are like the woke
olympics you know
yeah gold medalists oh yeah they just
can't do no three-time world
championships we're gonna social justice
work for everything that's happening in
the world
we got your back we are always in the
right you can tell when you go to like
anthony's channel it's all about like
the
the uh woke olympics like everything oh
yeah but is it he's also monetizing off
these people he came from me for coming
for did but also
did you give her any of that coin that
you made from that did video all about
her multiple personalities no i don't
think so and also how many personalities
do they all get to cut or do they
exactly do they share
paycheck to each of them okay and it's
like yeah i i
i'm so happy about this he he all right
deleting me put me in trash
let's all right delete put mikey in
trash i'm fine oh like
what is that straight to trash i have no
idea all right that's
dan that's like when it doesn't go to
the recyclable bin right
i think that just straight up deletes it
no recycle
is that right did i okay i don't know i
kind of just like i was going yeah
they're always in the right
or white okay so anyway so maybe you can
you can recap this better but someone
this one girl another swoop is that
right did i get that right
swoop watch her video uh here i've got
it here
oh wait [ __ ] [ __ ] cancel [ __ ] there's
too much of this [ __ ]
uh mother of god where is it okay here
swoop yeah swoop made this video and
she's like and it's an hour long dude
you you i love it
you beauty [ __ ] edit your [ __ ] i'm
just yes you are
oh can i just say you're wrapped up in
all these people's lives and they all
like it's an
hour long i'm not but can i just and she
just pulls every point like i'm
interested in what she has to say but
she
pulls every point like out to the mat i
loved every minute
where i just wanted [ __ ] wrapped
around my neck and hang myself i loved
every minute i wish it was longer
and kind of say i'm not in the beauty
community but each of hollywood story
reached out to me and they wanted they
called me in for an interview on the
beauty community i'm like i'm not in the
beauty community but i'll like i'll go
head-to-head with them all day long like
i [ __ ] can't stand them i love that
they're being brought down no one gets a
[ __ ] about the beauty community anymore
it's amazing
so mikey glam and gore yeah wait what
was the question
okay so this girl swoop made an hour
long video that should have been 15
minutes
yeah but i was in trades because she
says mikey is a homophobic oh this is
what you said
anyway she's like she's the worst person
ever she uses people of color she hates
gay people she says she's walk she hates
james charles and then what do you
tweeted this
you said and i quote mikey is a
homophobic
[ __ ] that's the lowest type of scum on
the internet
she mocked mental illness before so no
surprise
stupid yeah let's cancel these
fakes those who seem most perfect in pc
are the evil rats behind closed doors
i feel like you've said that about me to
be fair for sure not you no no no
because
i feel like you've said something very
similar you're very open about being
kind of like
not perfect not pc like so i'm not about
canceling people that can like take
accountability grow
learn blah blah blah first of all this
girl is not young so she's old enough to
know better but two the fact that she's
so high mighty her anthony they don't
apologize for [ __ ]
and you know what i'm gonna back that
like this girl might not want me to back
her the soup girl should i like trish
please you're the last person because i
know when i come to people's defense
like trish you've also done and i'm the
first to say like yeah i've done
horrible shot on the internet i'm the
first to say it but i'm also going to
keep calling people other people out and
holding accountability i think i've
grown since people called me out so i
will call out people too
and this [ __ ] i think should be
canceled because she's actually
homophobic and evil like the girl
this best friend released these private
text messages right everyone was so
scared jeffrey was going to release like
talk he's like he's going to release all
the receipts on us
if you're a racist homophobic person
behind closed doors you should be
exposed what
i'm never scared jeffy's going to
release things because guess what i'm
not a [ __ ] homophobic [ __ ] behind
like i'm not texting people like oh they
get [ __ ] because you know what my golden
rule is on the internet
is don't say anything behind closed
doors that you wouldn't say publicly
or yeah or why are they saying this
anyways behind closed doors like there's
never a time where i'm just like just
trashing people oh they get [ __ ] before
because they're gay or when they're
back up
[Laughter]
so do you i kind of want to look at
specifically what she said or yeah
is that too deep no we can go but do you
not just hate her because she's dating
no absolutely not because at first then
she rolled her eyes at me being like oh
my god this girl thinks she has a mental
illness which by the way
[ __ ] you [ __ ] and i'm gonna say it
again i said this dancing i'll say it to
mikey you guys don't know my mental
[ __ ] health like you
like how she's like oh my god she's
making a video about this hi mikey
you're
texting people behind culture's making
fun of gabby hannah's belly button
saying oh you have it so hard because
you're white
button yeah she literally texted
something about gabby and i'm being like
look at this look i hate gabby hannah
too like i actually hate that girl cause
she lied on me but i would never just in
my freak what did you say about her
belly button screenshot and she goes
wow look at this bitch's belly button
like where is it what's wrong with her
belly button
i mean i don't know let me get a picture
of my belly button no no
well i'm just curious if i mean like how
incredible must it be to comment i've
never commented on someone's belly
button and gabby has a lot of
ugly characteristics inside you don't
have to go for her ugly characters on
the outside you know what i mean and i
would never be that hateful just like
casually on my i feel like she would
hear you say that and be like thank you
she's like thank you are you being
serious no i'm being serious yeah like
don't go for that let's hear your belly
button oh that's the picture she sent
that's the one mikey sent to the girl in
the group chat
oh it's like it is i mean it's she's got
a she's very fit
i've got no comment okay yeah i mean
that's the thing like she's fine
what would you say you wanted to say
something look i really don't look at
people's appearances like that's not my
particular taste of
you know attractive but that's fine a
lot of people don't find me attractive
whatever but i would never just sit on
my couch and text you look at this
girl's [ __ ] up belly button like
that all right but that's not the worst
thing she said trust me there's like a
whole lot of things
it looks fine i think she's like
photoshopped it i don't know yeah that
looks photoshopped
i think she just like raised her belly
button it looks crazy like her hips
but at the same time that mikey's
texting this to her friend she's
collabing with gabby and like being like
turning into gabby hannah and she's
clapping with james charles and she's
collabing with jeffree star
so the one that got me is that she did a
collab video with james charles
who is by the way enemy of the people
except the tick tockers charlie and no
no no no oh he is the enemy of the
people now james charles
enemy number one enemy number one i'm
happy to clap with you that being said
would you really sure yeah you like him
he unfollowed you though danny or he
trashed you
yeah no i think he's just like everybody
she knows yeah everybody i know
[ __ ] well anyway i love you james i
can't come for him
i love you james don't hate me because
i'm friends with uncle fester
you do look so cool i think anyways so
so he was tech
he she did a collab with james charles
and at the same time she was texting
this girl whoosh
about what a douche she is swoop yes
swoop
whatever i love soup by the way i love
her i've seen her out and about i didn't
know how calming her voice was i really
like her but
but wow am i right people
who does that no but seriously though
that is no but the thing she said
it just was like hateful the thing she
said
it's not one thing to be like yeah we
hate james he thinks he's so much better
than people she's like oh he's popular
because he's gay
oh yeah that was another thing he was
like jeffrey
yeah they're like it's because they're
gay and i'm straight and white and this
is not fair she said it to her friend
the swoop
who is i believe she's african-american
um she uh
is she half black okay so she was saying
she's out to dinner with all them and
they were like literally saying like oh
my god it's like so hard to be white
like
who like complains about that ever but
also in like this day and age of like
black lives matter like who complains
about that like what a crazy [ __ ] that
she doesn't
believe well what she said i think
you're taking it to the extreme
okay what she said if i recall was that
isn't it weird isn't it funny how
the two biggest creators in the makeup
scene are gay men
that's what she said okay but then there
was other texts about her
to her friend swoop saying like like
basically telling swoop the only reason
she's getting ahead of her is because
mikey is white you don't watch the whole
thing because she knows
that it's an hour long this is
ridiculous she goes into details about
how she constantly was like
telling her like oh it's because like
you're a minority and i'm white that's
why like i'm not getting these things
like
it was crazy i was like the most insane
things that i've ever heard
and then also to be like it just feels
kind of dumb the whole thing
i'm sorry two of the biggest social
justice warriors are
are allowed to get away with this
because what they're white and straight
that's literally her whole point is
people will be like
it's fine we forgive her forgive her for
what for being an actual racist
homophobe in a private text message like
you're actually racist it's not jokes
it's not you know like the stuff that
you got canceled for we're like yeah
no these are text messages she said
isn't it funny how the two biggest
uh beauty people are gay men
which sounds bad but it's was no there
was more text than just that about them
being gay
hold up dan there was a time watching
the whole no the hour long video is like
oh i'm not gonna watch you know
if she really cared she would have made
it 15 minutes
no but basically then when this girl
swoop had a sexual assault thing about
her she posted it on social media now
she tried to check us mikey for seven
months mikey never responded
and then she finally made a made a thing
saying like hey i was actually assaulted
so mikey tries to get on that bandwagon
because of course her and anthony have
to get on every [ __ ] social justice
warrior bandwagon
she's like hey girl can i retweet your
story about sexual assault like just
trying to retweet
yeah i don't need my permission for that
retweet me
so then the girl was pissed rightfully
so she goes you fake [ __ ] like you're
really gonna be like now that i had like
a sexual assault case like you're now
you're gonna white pony me what so
anthony can do another series i sat down
with a sexual assault victim
huh what's a white pony did i say a
white pony i don't know what i just i
don't think i said white people oh
you're just saying [ __ ] i thought you
knew what you were saying i was like wow
what's a white pony i've never heard
that i thought it was like a white
elephant or something
a white horse what's a white horse
coming in on a white horse oh
yeah you were way off a white pony
the [ __ ] that coming in on your white
pony
to save the day
oh just go watch this video because
honestly like just all this [ __ ] she's
done like
it's just constant gaslighting
manipulation just being like hey was
that about me and then having her manage
your text is that about lauren like
if you think it's about you then you're
you have like what are the [ __ ] if you
have skeletons in your closet like you
know all [ __ ] like that like make sure
the maids aren't coming you know that
[ __ ] like it's like it's so [ __ ]
up and like the fact that you don't care
is the reason anthony and mikey get
passes because they're straight and
they're white and they're like whatever
nobody cares about them that much so
they get a free pass yeah nobody cares
about them they're forgettable as [ __ ]
you definitely just hate them because
they trash you not at all because people
trash me all the time
but they got they got really under your
skin no you know why because it was a
personal thing like i literally had
tried to kill myself like three times
last year and i did not know how i did
that
i thought you might want to apologize
after we did an episode like two
weeks ago where you started crying and
everyone in the comments was like wow i
feel like i really
got it and i feel like maybe he'll
actually apologize for because
you know a lot of people are like wow
that really effective hair he actually
doesn't care he just does this to get
the views and my bet
is him and mikey are gonna break up
because he's so [ __ ] vain and like oh
you think he'll leave her
oh for sure that would be kind of for
sure because there's
if he's like he's like he's like will
say that
that's bad you are you are not woke like
i thought oh yeah
yeah but neither is he he doesn't give a
[ __ ] he's fake as [ __ ] and everyone i
know i'll use the same james charles
everybody i know has a problem with him
too because he's
fake okay fake people no not whatever we
have to keep going for them mikey should
be okay what more's to say i mean you've
been talking to them
mike and logan paul should be the only
two people should be canceled everyone
else should be held accountable even
david dobrik who i like whatever i don't
really like him but he should be held
accountable not canceled logan what does
david dobrik do
oh he's done a bunch of racist stuff and
he never once called out for oh my god
he did blackface with peanut butter him
and zayn they did blackface they did a
bunch of indian jokes
asian jokes like that kind of [ __ ]
they've done so he did an underage joke
too
he did one about like a five-year-old
was cute no i get it but if you're gonna
hold one person accountable they
straight up cancel chain off the
internet if you're gonna cancel chain at
least hold david doberg [ __ ]
accountable don't give him a perfume and
billboards and all this money for
tick-tock and his disposable shitty
camera app
like hold everybody [ __ ] accountable
not just because he's cute and young and
straight
whatever i don't know but wait okay
whatever i'm not kidding
exactly i'm not gonna touch david dobrik
i'll get [ __ ] buried alive
he literally doesn't even like post
anymore but youtube's dead
i actually like david i met him once he
was really nice yeah of course a
sociopath is nice [ __ ] you think he's
a sociopath he
maintains a lot of friendships you think
yeah why do you think because he has
clout because you think people are all
using yours look at jason he's like oh
my god anything for you david i'll
[ __ ] leave churchill for you
yeah but you also hate jason they're
just users they're just fake as [ __ ] i
went at the night i went to the hospital
they came and then i never heard from
either like david never called me again
i spent two years with him like
every single day filming vlogs with them
and then just never contacted me to say
are you okay
like hey you try to kill yourself like
are you are you okay yeah and you got
screenshots you want to read some
uh that's so much i i
haven't found a specific yeah it's a lot
it's too much you got to edit that [ __ ]
down yeah
i need it can she re-release this as 15
minutes i think we'll get more videos
check out deaf noodles channel he he
recaps everything i follow him on
twitter he's got such gossip good gossip
yeah death noodles
i like following him on twitter he has a
ton of videos on me and i kind of he
does a lot on gabby too and i can hear
for them
sometimes he he did it one of me or he
did
did he do one of you he did oh yeah oh
yeah he
i was like i don't like that tank but i
still like him
i was like i don't like that tech patch
you can say a [ __ ] to a guy i think
because you're a guy okay let me ask you
something we've talked about all this
stuff and i i feel like this episode
actually sucks
oh i love this episode because i would
honestly just do this on my channel but
then i look petty if i just do it out of
nowhere but because we're on a podcast
we're talking about current topics so
it's like but i feel like if we talk
about it it's better if we have the
receipts where we can read the
well there was receipts and you didn't
want to read them well i didn't know we
were going to go like in on it you know
what i mean
there's a video do i look like megan fox
no not even close
like literally not even close
she's so tiny she's like 80 pounds i
love skinny people i'm like really upset
with skinny people it's very weird
okay okay so there's a i've heard
there's a video of you on only fans of
you wrestling your sister
topless with your mom in the reference
we're not wrestling topless we're in
swimsuits we're in like
red swimsuits why is that only fans
though it seems kind of [ __ ]
yeah because i think it's more like well
for money
yeah yeah so are you comfortable with
people beating off to you and your whole
family
that seems awkward yeah why i feel like
that's a natural thing
but i find i find it funny because
you're like i didn't only fans remember
when i did that only fans video with you
guys in the background
actually not i don't think i saw that
thank god
well it's a thing this podcast might not
have been a thing if i saw that
it was great i actually got a lot of
people on it
um you criticized elo's family because
you're like oh my god my family accept
me and they don't ask questions you know
like meanwhile my family's doing only
fans with me i mean let's [ __ ]
they're so open i think they're too open
is it too open no
yes no people who critique and i'm just
going off on another different tangent
your sister wrestled you in a bikini and
jello for dudes to beat off while your
mom refereed
yeah that's [ __ ] weird they're too
open shaming sex workers
i'm not shaming sex worker i just think
it's weird that you're playing up incest
with your family
first not nigh incest well why do you
think people are i like it
incest is having sex with a family
member it's incest porn no
you like it's it's in the if you were to
if you if
you were to categorize this porn if you
went in like pornhub you're like
let me look up the category it would be
under incest now you're kink shaming
well yeah some kinks should be shamed no
that's about like pedophilia
coming king shame pedophiles that's not
that's not a king that's an actual crime
age play is a kink yeah
but that incest is a crime okay but
that's not you can't [ __ ] your sister
trisha
it's illegal go to onlytrish.com if
we're going to talk about this
don't only trish.com 18 plus you can get
the video for the next 72 hours you keep
asking for a commission on the
highlights how about i get a piece of
the only trish cause
you that's gonna be a commission on the
freaking highlights yeah give me a cut
of your own choice.com
i haven't promoted i haven't plugged it
because i didn't think it's appropriate
but now i'm going to we're going to talk
about this and you're going to [ __ ]
put that [ __ ] everywhere we're going to
anyway
your family's too open you have no space
to criticize i hate people who shame sex
workers
i'm not shaming you sex workers you do
you're just as bad as keemstar now
keemstar shamed sex workers yeah you
guys are all awful it's all
middle-aged white men i'm not sure i
think it's weird that you're making
incest porn with your family
it's like when we role play if i'm like
hey pretend i'm your sister it's just a
kink
but she is your sister i'm talking about
moses and me
you guys could pretend you're siblings
yeah so that's the oh that's fine but
she's your sister
first of all we're not having sex we're
not even touching each other you guys
were wrestling
as i understood it i didn't do you want
to tell us all my only fans
no what if i give you a cut of that
i think it would be funny if we wrestle
do it because you would probably destroy
me
you probably i don't think i could lift
you off me yeah i'm a great wrestler
we're probably in the same weight class
but no that's a hard note
because it's not sexual though
oh uh no i was trending last time i was
here too for my only fans because of the
toilet paper in my ass
dude people actually okay yeah last week
you were trending on twitter because
apparently
you so you had this picture where you
pulled your
you're showing your [ __ ] and there
was toilet paper in your [ __ ]
and i would think wow that's really
disgusting and embarrassing
but you got more signups as a result oh
my god my only pants is popping i had to
do like another toilet paper video
so last time people like that people are
so weird
although to be fair i think the people
on your only fans are the [ __ ] real
purpose no they know it's clean then
that's what people were saying like i
like seeing however because i know you
wiped
who doesn't wipe their ass bidet users
oh should they prefer the wiper yeah
they're like i like to see that so you
did another one where you have toilet
paper in your ass
moses did you take that photo no he's
such a lie
the rolls-royce one you took the one the
original one
i knew you took that in the back alley
of his house yeah yeah i was like i
guarantee moses took this photo
yeah what was the video actually and he
said you're
i can't believe more people are going
because you took that he usually tells
me he but he couldn't see it in the sun
but usually he'll be like oh like just
rinse because you have something like
toilet paper because i do wipe a lot i
just like wipe a lot i have a lot
whatever i like wiping making sure i'm
clean so he'll tell me but i said now
you can't tell me if there's a toilet
paper in there like make sure there is
some paper in there because that's like
a thing now people like
so that is so fast um
that is so foul that you're that's like
cleaning my ass
no because there's no [ __ ] in it price
hilton he's zoomed in he's like she's
waxed and she's clean what's the big
problem
i literally put like dildos up there to
clean it out so there's never [ __ ] in
there
it's the cleanest [ __ ] you'll ever
see yeah i mean that's what everyone
does like gay guys do it
you clean with a dildo that's what you
do yeah like you put soap on it and [ __ ]
no i just want like like when i after
like douching it out like putting the
water up there then you kind of put the
dildo into like
to see if it comes anything comes out
but nothing ever does i'm clean
that's disgusting especially with your
diet
that's so i'm mean i'm trying to eat
better now i'm trying to eat healthier
how do you
eat healthier i've been eating really
what'd you eat today so far okay well it
was my tick tock so i did my
um my dunkin donuts and my hebrew cereal
gross yeah all right
we're coming to the end here what are
you gonna do for your anniversary this
weekend
we're going to a hotel on friday okay
that's good because when you guys said
on your action anniversary you just went
to breakfast i was like that's your
interview no yeah no it it's just it's
impossible because theodore's young
we don't have help on the weekends
watching them on friday we're going to
bring them to my parents
and the doggies do you want to bring him
here to my house
uh why so he can be in the background
one of your famous [ __ ] toilet paper
shots
no i wouldn't do only fans with him no
100 no
you don't trust his uncle you're you're
not even comfortable around him when he
comes out
i love him he's like the best part of
this house like that's the only reason i
like coming is to see him because he's
always so happy he's smiling
like i love him i trust him with his
grandparents how about his uncle at the
end
no i don't you don't want to trust moses
to watch him
i mean i would trust moses to watch him
for a couple hours if we need to go not
overnight
no no wow
i don't think he's shocked by that okay
yeah so easy
such a baby like it's so easy
he would definitely i would come back
and he would be dead that's so
not true when you say that that's with
me when i say when you say that i was
like wow you would definitely he would
be dead
how long have you gone for it two nights
yeah just two nights
okay and what do you have planned room
service
that's hot i thought it was hot either
level room service just room service and
we're trying to um conceive yeah did you
oh is that why you picked that weekend
and not your anniversary weekend
well actually she was doing this she was
ovulating
this she's like ovulating right now oh
[ __ ] so you're gonna go back in this
roleplay and be like hey ella
yeah she what you really wanna [ __ ] me
you wanna [ __ ] i'll go fester girl do
you only have sex when you guys are
ovulating
i feel like that's you no you keep
asking me all the time about this [ __ ] i
feel like you just say it to like say
face like oh once a week but i feel like
you only do it when you're out she's not
relating which is that i love it
no no she did that i get honey hornier
when i be late like i'll be later this
weekend i was like can you just come and
sign me
disgusting you [ __ ] get her pregnant
he did the day before the day after but
not the day
you're on birth control no are you doing
a condom nope
you're gonna [ __ ] get her pregnant
you psycho do you understand what you're
doing
it would be a miracle because it is
really hard for me to get pregnant oh
right right i forgot seriously i mean
it's not
right i forgot i i swear like my last
relationship you had fertility tests how
do you know that yeah i did the hsg test
which that's when they should i talk
about this all the time and so they
shoot that stuff in you
see the neon stuff to see if it goes
through and it's just like it's just i
have some blockage so they can like
scrape it off or whatever but i haven't
done that yet
but i mean it could go through so you're
saying if i get pregnant it's an act of
god
no i don't think that i mean they said
they're like oh you there's like you
know you can get pregnant but it's just
harder because your tubes are blocked
right now but
i was in a relationship for like two
years and he came to me every day for
like six times they never got pregnant
so
disgusting but moses thinks his sperm is
like super sperm because he like is
scared to do it on the day of
so well i don't blame him you should not
you should take more precautions if you
ask me
no we're like down i feel ew
no but like the day after
the day after is pretty risky and the
day before there's basically like a
five-day window moses just to warn you
but she doesn't she doesn't explain to
you she goes oh the day after is fine
no you don't there's like why not show
you when i'm up i even say i'm ovulating
today like please come inside you guys
really want to have a baby already
go ahead tell the truth
is everything could you imagine i'm so
excited i just don't have a baby i just
really i feel like that's my calling
like [ __ ] everything i'll [ __ ] this
podcast bye i'm gonna have a baby now
like that would be me no nannies no
offense but you know what i mean you'd
get a nanny
definitely not you would definitely get
naked i don't want the baby to like
connect with someone else like that
only connect with me i don't even want
to connect with the dad i'm just like
connecting with me you hear that
she's not kidding that's a joke that's a
joke actually
are you gonna leave her single mom
yeah he thinks that he really thinks i'm
going to like kidnap the baby you're
like a black widow you're going to eat
him
when you get pregnant is that a prank
mantis i mean a pregnancy oh my wait is
that a thing
yeah they eat the they [ __ ] and then
they eat the mail
kind of everything kind of iconic yeah
wow i know
so anyway that's about it i i don't know
so we have an announcement in like three
months be like hey
i would tell you earlier i would tell
you earlier like the five week mark i'd
be like oh hey pregnant
i know you're not supposed to but i'm
trying to think of this is i'm really
trying to be honest with
like if you guys got pregnant
i think you would both be really good
parents but i don't think this
relationship would work out
if we had a baby yeah okay if we didn't
have a baby think it would work out
not forever just being honest why tell
me i'm
curious because i because
i don't know i mean it seems like you
have trouble well you both have trouble
with commitment to be frank
so ma i don't know but but like yeah you
have a track record of not going the
long run
yeah i don't think it has anything to do
with you guys personally i mean you guys
i gotta be honest you guys are
really happy you're really good together
you're very cute and you seem very
sincere
right but i'm just saying the track
record is that
you have trouble in the long run i say
that all the time i get scared about
that and i think you're someone who gets
bored
easily yeah and also you're someone
who's kind of like like you
self-admittedly you're kind of like a
sex addict
and so you may get bored of sleeping
with one guy
that's not true i'm actually like i
actually like a break like when we have
my period you like a break
now i do because that sucks too much
well you guys have exactly but you guys
have only been dating you're still new
i'm taking a break from stuff after two
years you might
you might want a new dick no that's not
true
i think just in general i push people
away and like that i think that's the
thing i do
um but i don't think it would happen
with moses he's pretty good like
sometimes i try and push him away and
he's like still here you know
so now i'm like oh this is a good one i
think it pushed me away because of me
not because of that i'm just like oh i
feel like this person can like
break my heart but i feel like i feel
and also with a baby for me i even tell
them it's like i would have a baby just
on my own like without a guy you know
what i mean like i just want to be like
a mom i'd have like six kids like perez
hilton i'd just like
like have someone carry my baby or i'll
carry it or whatever get a sperm donor
and um so i think i just want kids but i
mean also like i don't know but
yeah but that's too much commitment to
be like forever you know i don't want
anyone else
and it's so hard dating and i hate being
alone
but the baby yeah and we have a baby
together so it's different i don't know
i don't you mean i think i should wait
on the baby though i can't wait much
longer because wait like a year
regardless like well you're pretty young
how old are you you're like 32.
yeah you're young but i already have
problems with fertility like it's
already hard for me to get pregnant
and so that's why i was like oh [ __ ] and
like the older you get so like
regardless let's say memos broke up
today i would like literally go to a
sperm donor and get like sperm you know
what i mean
like i actually get like yeah i've done
it before i
went through fertility treatments before
when i was single
so i just want to be your family's gonna
trip when they hear this now
the house was bad enough the baby oh
brother they've accepted me now that
they said that their happiness in a
relationship
that's awesome i'm really happy to hear
that yeah how's the house shopping going
we won't know until the 15th of october
because my taxes get filed on the 15th
so they need my personal taxes for 20
years oh
right but i think it's i think it'll be
good because the guy you gave us is so
boring
with the guy he gave us i think um i
think is he's like he's optimistic we
told him our hurdles and he's like
optimistic yeah he's good he's the real
deal and i feel like it's gonna be good
like i feel
although yeah cool we'll see i mean
hopefully
wait but if we have a house i mean
that's like a bigger commitment than a
baby
wow you're [ __ ] really that's the
that's
such a dumb thing to say are you serious
i mean it's harder to like split wow
you're not ready for kids i think you're
not ready for five kids
i want at least three having a house is
more of a commitment
yeah i feel like financially that's a
card like who's gonna leave like who's
gonna be kicked out
i guess the man usually gets kicked out
do you know what it's like to share
custody with the child
i do i had divorced parents you think
that's easy easier than a house
uh yeah for sure i think they didn't
want to give up the house more than they
didn't care about giving us up that
explains
all this hey i turned out fine you know
having two christmases two birthdays
ain't a bad thing
you're saying turned out fine i was like
oh [ __ ] oh my god look who's talking
hey i would never say i turned out the
most dysfunctional family i literally
would never say i turned out fine
even though i did i turned out okay
unfortunately just because you make
money
but you're way crazier than that that's
so not true but you're way crazier than
me
that's not true bro that's objectively
you're
you hide it more just like mikey who
hides [ __ ] oh really
gets brought to the circle i don't hide
everything i literally don't you've
literally just said how honest i am and
you respect that about it but you hide
the crazy is what i'm saying yeah you
care a lot i don't hide you do hide the
crap i'm all out there
with no [ __ ] eyebrows and everything
you were into pills you never talk about
that that you were a pill addict for a
minute
what yeah you said that you said you
were really into pills and you don't
talk about that
why do i need to talk about that because
that's being open that you're judging me
for being crazy
taking pills or whatever like i take out
pills or whatever but you've done it too
and you're just not open about it
i don't think that that is a defining
characteristic of who i am i think that
is a big thing that makes sense why
because you're on medication now and
there's no shame or judgment in it but
like hey if you're going to shame me for
being
off meds you should say hey i'm on meds
i'm not shaming you for being off beds
that's what it sounds like you just call
me crazy but here's what you need you
know what you just did
you're trying to see this is why you are
such a dangerous person
especially to be close with because
you'll take something that i've told you
and
you'll take something that somebody told
you in confidence and you'll use it
you'll weaponize it against them
that's not true that's what you just did
no and luckily for you i don't care and
i'm okay with it
but you go oh well you're i told you an
anecdote about how i used to take like
what's like tramadol back in israel when
i was like bored in a dead-end job
and you literally just weaponized that
against me you call me crazy
knowing my history bro we always call
you crazy you're like
up front you're gonna call me crazy then
i'm gonna say okay once you open up to
what you've done that's
so crazy okay i'm joking around and then
you go okay so what
what do i have to weaponize against
ethan oh he told me you should take
bills in israel
i don't think he's ever said that so
here i'm gonna drop that on him you want
me to weaponize you because i have
things i could actually weaponize you
with
i don't know no but i don't do it
they're certain you just did it moses
said there's certain things about him i
would never
say threaten me with doing it more
that's why you're so dangerous you can't
do that
no i didn't because you do that to
everybody i know personal things about
you and do i say it no you literally
just did
that's not that personal because you
just called me crazy being off my
medication so therefore i didn't say
anything about being off your medicine
and then you asked me i literally didn't
mention being off your medicine then you
asked me
i said you're crazier than me oh i said
i said you're not open and honest with
everything you're like yes i am but i'm
like are you though and then you were
pushing
not that i'm hiding that i took pills
it's just you used it it's not a
character push somebody to the level of
like saying this this and this and then
i'll be like
now you're weaponizing me you push and
push and push
constantly you're [ __ ] you you're
[ __ ] up
you're the pusher and the gaslighter be
like oh my god how could you say that
about me meanwhile this whole time being
like
i'm not you're crazy oh we're just
joking but then you go to another level
no everything i'm talking about is on
the table right okay mine's on the table
too
everything we always talk about so but
you're like okay what can i use to
really hit him right now
that's what you do [ __ ] gaslighting
one over bro i'm not gaslighting this is
what you do to people no
i'm just telling you you just push and
push and push i don't know i'm not
pushing it you do
you do you push so hard you get that for
everyone
it's all here i'm not like crazy is
goofing around
that's so offensive okay i mean i've
called you crazy a lot i don't know that
it's offense
of so offensive dude in this situation
yes okay but
i don't come for a meeting i'm
weaponizing you when you put then say
you know what i don't appreciate you
calling me crazy instead of being crazy
i'll tell you everything it's not what
do i weaponize myself
so why should i why should i ask myself
by being like why should anybody ever
confide in you
i'm not saying you i never said you're
offering you didn't invite me you're not
like hey i gotta tell you something real
serious like oh yeah
god forbid anyone ever does that that's
so rude well you know what no it's not
your life is sad and pathetic and mine
is happy thriving so good
have fun on your beach weekend eating
room service
trying to get pregnant have fun with
that
that doesn't sound sad and pathetic that
sounds like a good family life like i
have good fulfilling
and good deep roots with a wife that
i've been married to for a long time
i've got a family that we're trying to
build
and i've got stability in my life
there's something right there i could
weaponize but i'm not going to you know
why because
you push and push and i'm not going to
push on your buttons the way you push on
other people's buttons i wouldn't even
say oh there's something i could
weaponize i wouldn't even say that
because you're saying i weaponize and i
don't there's a perfect
time to go in there and be like actually
this well because obviously you have
i don't know what you're thinking about
but like and i don't consider
weaponizing i'm very open about
everything
if someone brings up something that i
don't want people to bring up with i'll
openly talk about it fine whatever
that's just [ __ ] me like i don't care
i'll talk about it
it's not weaponizing just because i
bring something up it definitely i'm
just being i'm just trying to tell you
of something you do i'm just trying to
be honest that i think you have why
you're wrong
on this one but why do you think that
like all your friendships like a lot of
your friendships
for so many all of your boyfriends and
relationships that's what i'm worried
about moses is that she's got a roll of
dicks of all this [ __ ] on you
and then and then when [ __ ] goes wrong
she's going to try to ruin your [ __ ]
life i'm wrong and i don't expose stuff
i know like
well yes you did no i didn't well you
did accuse him of [ __ ]
kind of flirting with underage girls no
that wasn't it that was not
well that was kind of [ __ ] up no we
you're like oh i had a fight i'm going
to accuse him being with the underage
group i'm not accusing him of everything
the dm's were out there they were
publicly
put out there yeah they were they were
posted by your all account and i had
like three likes
we know that that wasn't it literally
had three likes
okay but anyway not confirmed by me
i'm just saying it's not cool to be like
oh well you're addicted to pizza i've
had friends for a very long time i have
friendships that have lasted well over
10 years i'm still friends with
andrew jefferson jeffrey i've been
friends with for like a year and a half
oh that's kidding see
that would also be considered oh that's
weaponizing against me but now it's a
joke because why you're you're the one
that told me he unfollowed you
funny anything you say those are jokes
those are jokes it's all on the table
this is how guys do with girls oh my god
you sweat pills the story i told you
wasn't on the table
okay but that's not weaponizing you yes
it is oh
oh really you talk about stuff all the
time that's like what about when you
push and push push with me to show you
how much i made on that video you're
like you do this you do this you were
[ __ ] being and
it's all on the table not on the table
you forced me you were literally get
your phone out [ __ ]
do this right now like you couldn't you
never told me no you did i said please
don't please edit this out it's on the
podcast i was like begging there's like
tears in my eyes like please edit this
out because
like i really didn't know so that's me
being an [ __ ] but it's all on the
table
it's not okay you weaponized it whatever
it's not what you were you thought
you pushing someone to do something
they're not comfortable with that's what
that's worse that's [ __ ] way worse
i'm not saying i'm insane at it or i
don't know all but you are you're awful
you are awful yeah you got better
i am all full but i'm just saying that
you recognize people and push people
like pushing people to do stuff they
don't want to do and you've done it
multiple times on multiple
shows and it's just not cool i mean
that's why people get so annoyed with
you when you interview people which is
probably why we don't have guests on
this show because people don't want to
be
on this show or your h3 show anymore
people just don't want to have people
that's
all every week oh really oh wow they're
really killing it who was
like i don't even know the doctor with
coronavirus like good guys that was like
five months ago okay well i don't even
watch your thing but i'm just saying
like all the guests you get
they're not bill burr is not coming on
bo burnham's not coming on crystalline
is not coming on you know what i'm
saying you're getting people that no one
knows
oh jack's films again great good job
good guest just get all your friends
idubs wow good job
our guest track record but i feel like
we've had some bangers lately
happy though sure okay well that's all
that's about it yeah sure
let's see whitney comments was just
posted when you came on is she
acceptable to you
yeah whitney's fine okay good job having
a girl on that's the other thing you're
very misogynistic can you help mommy
and chris christine have no idea who
they are how many people do you get
no idea how many views andrew santino
i don't think people know who these
people are but hey famous comedians cool
don't know any of them um stevo um
also misogynistic but okay keep going
bobby lee
and kalila another female we've got some
really good guests coming up too here
i'll promo them right now
okay promo that i hope i get some some
more views to the h3 podcast
oh you know i here just for you i'm
gonna premiere i'm just gonna give this
away for you right now
belle delphine is gonna be on on the
29th whoa holy [ __ ] how did you get her
exactly
whoa so [ __ ] eat up unboxing her
stuff is real great
i'm gonna get a million views you know
my [ __ ] it doesn't have toilet paper
in it oh okay so
you got better feeling when you unboxed
off no one even cared and even get a
million views so wow
yeah that's dead and done just like
james charles you're just trying to be
but my life isn't about views
it literally is about views all you care
about is like working doing this you're
literally projecting on me you call me
money hungry and it's like literally all
you do is just obsess over money
i mean i'm not saying i'm not saying
that see i hate when people that's
[ __ ]
weaponizing when people throw it back on
me i'm not saying i'm perfect person if
i call someone out for being gracious
doesn't mean i haven't said racist
things in my past
it's also just being like hey you're
awesome i'm holding a [ __ ] mirror up
to you
no that's not true that is 100 true okay
whatever you
it's not projecting like i'm not saying
hey i love money too [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] give
me money but like
it's not just because you love money
doesn't mean that you have
insight to every single person you so
are no i'm not
we were gonna be 50 50 on the show
originally okay here's weaponizing
saying stuff that's not dude i gave you
the most
generous [ __ ] deal go ahead and said
actually 45 out of
45 55 like and you said to pay everyone
okay cool i get that cool but then to be
like and i'm just going to keep all the
highlights for
for costs or whatever okay how about
what like just reading we spent 50 000
on this set we have a full set of guys
that are working
all around the clock of our podcast and
i literally
and i and you get 45 that seems like a
great [ __ ] deal
of the highlights the highlights is
nothing but it's just it's just really
annoying to crunch
the numbers for a couple hundred bucks
over time it's gonna get money and it's
just like hey that's fine i don't care
but don't say i'm money
i'm money hungry i couldn't care less
like i'm like whatever i would do this
for free so you're not money hungry now
huh i like money i like money i'm not
money hungry i don't okay whatever this
is a stupid conversation
i'm just i all i'm trying to do is give
you an important insight
to this is something to do you
constantly like move on we're not
talking about that
this is stupid like how come you get to
dictate what's stupid and what's not and
what's worthy of a conversation
if you want to talk about something
bring a conversation yeah i'm fine i'm
fine with them saying but this is what
you do to your guests on the phone
why it's dying which is why no one's
coming back on which is why you don't
get repeat guess who's the guy that was
so offended when you were
he was so uncomfortable i forgot his
name we watched it and he was so
uncomfortable he's like what are you
doing like what's happening right now
i forget the guy's name eric eric
something air under i don't know
eric eric eric andre is that a thing you
don't even know who eric andre is no i
don't know but he looked very
uncomfortable i watched it i was like
what the [ __ ] is happening like why were
you being
so [ __ ] like you know what i mean and
it's like that's why people don't come
back because you have this way of just
pushing people always come back
billboard was on twice by the way did
you know that did not see the second
episode well it was great that's good i
hope it was better the second time
around
it was but i'm just saying in general
that's why no one comes back like
people always come back literally we
regularly have people back jack's films
good job
jack's films has been on the episode the
worst by the way so
why he's really nice he's not he was an
[ __ ] to be on the shane dawson
well maybe he should have been before i
was huh maybe he was right maybe he saw
something
no he's he's the most problematic and he
what jack's film is not i gotta not be
there no
see this one's saying i stopped you
don't you're trying to silence me but
here's the thing just like mikey
oh we're all woke and we're all pieces
i'm not saying he's woke
but he has a lot of skeletons in his
closet no he doesn't and that's not me
weaponizing that's just me saying i know
no but like you did the pill anecdote
that was you
that was not oh my god but that okay so
what what do you call what you did to me
when you push and push a push when i say
i'm not comfortable with something like
that well you could accuse me of being
an [ __ ] that's not being an [ __ ]
like pushing someone when they say i'm
uncomfortable it's not weaponizing
private info
that is that totally is because you have
the power in the shop
something obvious okay it's was my only
question to you is
um what who won world war ii
who won world war ii was it the allies
or the
last episode was it the allies or the
axes who won world war ii winning this
episode i'm quitting you can put you can
literally tell this last episode
did the nazis win or lose world war ii
i'm over this
i'm so over this and yo i really am like
100 done with the show
so this is it yeah so i'm gonna
negotiate my terms and maybe i'll come
back but that's it renegotiate you
already have max terms
you're maxed out i don't think so after
this today i'm
pre-negotiating you want to give me 25
000 for the set
no so what do you want because i haven't
seen the set
i didn't have a say in how it was like
built or anything i had my set designers
like oh they're not available
i tried to reach them
all right whatever well good luck with
this channel it's doing great
is it okay yeah it's doing fine okay
cool
i'm not the first woman when mine's
dying don't turn around like what's your
view cause i'm the first time that my
channel is dying my channel's not done
oh okay cool love it doing better than
ever
yeah actually well we're posting more
frequently but the views are up it's
doing really good
amazing happy for you but you're trying
to see what you're trying is to upset me
but it's
i'm not i said good [ __ ] for you if you
think it's doing bad
i'm not i think that's amazing if it's
doing good for you then really congrats
yeah i can see why your relationships
don't work out
i can see why you've been with the same
person for 12 years thank you you have
no other options and
quite frankly i don't blame you i have
no wow that's a really
so why would i want other options
i'm perfectly content i can you know i
could be mean like you but i'm not going
to
anything else we should discuss damn
just went off the [ __ ] rails
wow uncle fester and whatever this [ __ ]
you threw together
oh my god mine's more iconic we'll see
why the tick tock view should we make up
or are we
hating i'm literally over it i'm so over
it i don't think everyone breaks up with
me over there bye
why would moses break up over a podcast
because i don't like his family
and i don't like hanging out with you
guys and you guys are awful and that's
it and yeah i said it
but you liked me when we started i was
trying to be nice and fun but
i actually don't really care that much
for you really you never liked me
nope i think oh you're the next to be
canceled
you're really upset no i'm not
i'm fine so have fun
good luck on the baby making thank you
i feel that you're really upset huh
okay you're shutting down
no i'm good what else do you want to
talk about let's talk
should we resolve decisions no i'm okay
i'm so over it
you just said let's talk i'm not doing
the next episode for real i'm over it
you just said let's talk
because you said oh you're shutting down
i'm like i'll talk to you talk
you got me for 10 more minutes no well
we're over
we're over time look it's too far this
episode went 20 minutes too long oh
some good content there tom
[Music]
anything else that's it moses do you
want to have anything to say
end it moses is warning me well just
because i'm quitting this show don't
fire moses because of meme
why would i fire moses because of you i
don't know people be doing that
you overestimate your influence oh i
know how you guys are with him oh my god
trisha did this oh my gosh i shouldn't
do that
oh we should be scared of trisha it's
like
i've never said anything like that i've
seen your group chat i literally see his
phone well you bragging about looking
through his phone isn't exactly the best
look i'm not bragging about it i'm
stating something because once again i'm
open well i've never said anything like
that
i'm open about it like yeah i'm not a
perfect person i'm a crazy person
sometimes like whatever i'm open about
it
i'm sorry for calling you crazy i know
this has been off the rails
yeah i apologize i don't apologize for
anything i said about you
that's okay then i'll say it again it's
fine but i
know that this one off the rails i know
you have issues because of your family
and i get it i understand that i'm
sympathetic to it so
my apologies but that's it but i i can
tell that when i said that
it upset you and i was sincerely i
thought we were goofing around because
well you look unhappy in life so i
really hope you feel better i know it
came from a place that you're right i
wonder
i know yeah because i thought i thought
we were
i thought we were goofing on each other
kind of thing but but i genuinely
i i'm sorry for saying that i'm i'm
genuine
okay and um i'm like literally gonna
leave that like once this is over
no i know so i'm trying i just wanna i'm
trying to resolve this
because the more we talk about it the
worst is gonna be like good luck
honestly good luck thanks for having me
on five episodes love it it was so much
fun
and i'm over it good luck and i'm sorry
about your family situation i'm sorry
about your situation
no my name is no you are i can tell i
can tell and it's sadness and i see you
when i was around your family that you
have sadness in you and it's sad
okay and that's why you're so mean to
people on the internet and i get it but
also don't take it out on people and
call them crazy and [ __ ] no i apologize
okay cool great that's a wrap i think
i do think you're a good person and i
and i am sorry for calling you crazy
well i'll weaponize you later then on my
channel can't wait for the weaponizing
everyone comes to me because i'm crazy
and i weaponize against people like it's
all me i never get provoked
yeah no i i can see why why why i
provoked you because i
can be like asshole-ish it's not [ __ ]
it's like literally like
pushing someone to do something when
they're uncomfortable that's like
literally like
it's an attack i mean that's literally
like
awful but anyways
right okay cool okay well well yeah
hey alfredo
well we're going out on a high note here
folks all for your viewing pleasure
just wire me for this later and we'll
talk never
i will wire you the money that i owe you
and i will wish you well because i've
always wished you well and i could tell
you're so you hate me so much right now
but i don't hate you
i know i like you still my feelings
didn't change for you there's no way to
calm you down i feel like i'm not i'm
i'm fine i'm literally
no but like there's no way you just hate
me so much i just wish there was a way
like yeah whatever there is because i
just i
i hate people just like that are you
you're the person i hate in this world
that's so just offensive and but they do
nothing wrong and
when people are provoked oh they're
crazy calling girls crazy and stuff like
that it's like
but taking no accountability no
responsibility you think everything's
just an attack against you everyone's
against ethan like
oh my gosh i'm always right it's like
ugh you and jacksonville serve each
other so
jax well i can't believe you're going
after jax he's such a sweet guy
i love you all right tricia
it's not you don't have to choose
between me and moses he can do both even
if we hate each other
he'll go with you bye yeah
no he drove here in my car bye trisha
are we gonna make tick tocks
are we gonna make tick tocks we were
supposed to make tick tocks
she's leaving yeah
i'll yeah well uh trisha left
so this is our first fight our big real
fight
she snapped on me and she left
i'm gonna try to do a post-mortem on
this um
i don't know maybe she's having a bad
day but i do
you want to comment moses moses came
back you want to sit down
go ahead get her phone yeah she's like
moses you
pic pick who you're staying with i was
like go ahead oh moses is here
just give it time okay yeah no i figure
all right bye moses love you love you
too buddy
i was genuinely feeling bad because but
i don't know because i feel like i
always
goof on goof with her like that right
dan yeah
yeah i don't know am i am i wrong to
think that she was kind of like
well maybe i shouldn't continue this
conversation without her probably it's
not fair probably not
i think i said my piece yep
but uh we hope to see trisha soon we
miss her
and i really genuinely am sorry i'm
laughing because dan's laughing
hmm
i don't know what i could have done i
was really trying to resolve the issue
and i
dude and trisha if you're watching this
please come back
uh we miss you already so that concludes
this episode of frenemies
more enemies today than friends
that really went off the rails
but i guess that's part of the thrill
well we said this was gonna happen
i'm actually surprised it didn't happen
sooner i don't know i thought i was
trying to feel like maybe
this well i i hope she'll be back i hope
she'll be back that's all i can say
all right guys we'll uh we'll see you in
i don't know what's the next episode but
hopefully next week
it might be a little longer than that
might be never i hope not because like i
said
i spent i invested so i'm trying to
recoup here at least
but all right guys i'll see you uh i'll
see you later